our final mystery guest is on the phone
right now is that correct chris brockman
correct
correct and do we just do i just get
right into it just like the last one
you should just say hello oh my god
brockman uh hello mystery guest number
three
yeah uh rich on the momentous occasion
of your birthday i'm calling in to say
happy birthday
and hope you are having a great one
and remember 52 is the new 51.
marv albert oh my gosh this is
um this is amazing i'm all i
i don't know what to say thank you my
god hey you've had some lineup i must
say
well you know it's my to use your phrase
my crack staff
marv it's my it's my crack staff
yeah they've done a fine job they've
hustled their way through
very nice oh how are you doing i'm doing
great i'm
so much better for talking to you marv
um wow i don't even know uh how to begin
other than to say um what's what what's
going on in your world marv
what's going on with you these days
basketball
series between atlanta and milwaukee i'm
currently in milwaukee
yes after uh trae young put on a
uh momentous show last night was
incredible
uh and uh that that's about it
and um so let's get into before
you um what you saw last night
how many players in your illustrious
career have you seen
shimmy prior to hoisting
an open shot and jarring it to quiet the
crowd how many times have you seen that
one marv
appropriately enough uh i'm doing the
east conference final with reggie miller
and i think i've seen reggie do
everything that
uh trey young has pulled off he did the
bow reggie did
yes you know what he was with the pacers
did it in chicago
and uh at the garden last week i thought
that was a great moment
he said it's what they do on broadway uh
according to trey young when you finish
up the show
yes and he certainly did that against uh
against the knicks but
now there haven't been too many uh you
know pistol pete maravich may have
done a few things in his day but there
have not been
uh this type of personality and
you know he's a nice kid and he handles
himself
so well particularly on post-game
interviews
but what what an offensive player you
know always finds space
puts up 48 points last night
against milwaukee and i think he
accounted for uh 72 of the points
between assists
uh and points for the uh for the hawk it
was a big surprise
uh that they took game one they they've
really been a
fun team to watch it's kind of a
cinderella story developing and nate
mcmillan the coach has done a great job
you know since taking over he's
like 36 and 15 now
so uh it's uh it's been a
certainly a different type of playoff
run uh
for the nba in a long time well
obviously because lebron
um you know he uh got bounced in the
first round
um right uh steph curry didn't make it
out of the state farm playing tournament
um if i say it correctly and and
you know marv i'm just trying to you
know there may be an eye on rich and
eisen but i am a team player when it
comes to the
association and um you know put it all
together
and this is i mean is this the most wide
open
playoffs that you we've witnessed in
quite some time marv
i i i i believe so i i i would agree
with
with that because yeah you have phoenix
a team that looked very strong and
seemed to come out of nowhere in the
bubble and they continue
right through the regular season uh the
clippers you know coming back from 2-0
twice
uh and now we'll have to do it again uh
and then atlanta to me has been a major
surprise milwaukee
not so much i i don't i don't think
they're a surprise i mean
you had the uh neptune philadelphia in
front of them but injuries
as you indicated played a major a a big
role in what is
what has taken place with some of the
other uh teams but even
the hawks who have some uh injured
players deandre hunter is a very
important guy in terms of
uh at the defensive end and uh the books
are actually pretty good shape they lost
dante uh d vincenzo who's an important
player but
uh these two teams uh are i mean who
knows what's gonna happen now i mean
the milwaukee has the home court
advantage but anything could happen in
this series
marv albert here on the rich eisen show
um
marv uh i i was just wondering this i'll
ask you
and i know you've spoken about it why
why now retiring why
why now for you well yeah i i just felt
uh
for several years that 55 years of doing
nba basketball would do it and i found
that
the pandemic although it was terrible to
see
you know what happened throughout the
country throughout the world in terms of
people getting sick people dying
obviously
but uh my family uh we were fortunate
uh in new york where it actually is
pretty good
right now and uh i found the pandemic
was like a rehearsal for retirement
i i enjoy reading i i became
uh mr tv binger i haven't had that
opportunity
probably ever uh you know working out
spending time uh with uh with
my family all that good stuff
and uh i kind of enjoyed it and i think
uh when i when you hit 80 you got to
start thinking about
stuff like that and you know we
certainly will take some
some trips uh and we have a place in
florida so we'll be down there so
i'm looking forward to it i i'm sure
that when
late october early november rolls around
there will be aspects of it that i miss
i love the preparation for the games i
love being around
uh uh particularly the production people
the
the coaches who you get to know
extremely well because they give
uh quite a bit of their time uh you know
to the broadcasters and you know the
just being around the whole scene
is is fun i know i'll miss that part of
it
uh there are some people i may not miss
uh former
color commentators like lazar mike
patello
you know calls every day it's very
annoying
oh man uh you know like last night
he he's somewhere in florida and he
uh he knows i have a game but he invites
me to dinner at the restaurant
that's he's had a piece of i'm dealing
with steve kerr too had a great sense of
humor we had a lot of fun we worked
together for about
eight years and uh he's he's a bit off
the charts
too in a good way uh with uh his kinetic
abilities so uh you know you missed that
kind of stuff but i'm sure i'll be
talking to all these people anyway
just so i am mandated to ask you marv
albert what what does marv albert binge
watch watch television shows are you
binge watching marv what do you got
you know i think i saw everything
because people keep telling me about new
shows and
uh i mean from ozark justified it was a
great
uh israeli show founder i ended up
watching a lot of french
and english shows with subtitles of
course
there's a there's one called call my
agent that rich i would recommend to you
did frederick vice suggest that one marv
that first no no
uh yes that was the uh that was a french
show yeah that was very funny
uh better call saul i enjoy it okay
uh i mean it goes on on recent ones uh
mara of the eastwood uh what else
uh another one i'd highly recommend
godfather of harlem with forest
awesome epics yeah farc farce whitaker
okay
very good right yeah i mean there are so
many good ones on right now
i like uh ted lasso yeah ted lasso is
funny marv
that is very funny sorry justice today
is terrific yes
very funny you could do some tv critic
work as well if you
want to just keep your toe in the water
here exactly that's
exactly my field yeah
oh marv albert here on the rich eisen
show um
in between games one and two of the
eastern conference finals what was it
like for you to get
that standing ovation in brooklyn marv
with the new york fans
to uh i was so surprised i mean it was
uh you know
so nice that they did that uh
i i you know i to get up and wave to the
crowd is something i've never done
but i said uh at the time grant hill was
working with me in that series
and i said this is embarrassing you know
you stand up and you wave
and people were so gracious uh
it really touched me you know uh i've
never had that
you know you see players getting those
type of uh
responses and ovations but it was really
nice because they
put stuff up on the board and grant is
saying watch watch the board up above
and i had no idea what he's talking
about you know
so uh yeah it was a very nice gesture
well it was it's it's a necessary
gesture marv i know you're being
humble but it is a necessary gesture um
in new york city um you were the voice
of so many seminal
basketball and hockey moments i might
add
um and for you to get uh
a moment in new york city was necessary
i truly believe that and i'm glad that
the nets were the ones to at least step
up and do it
mark well thank you rich but yeah as i
said it was it was
really extremely nice uh my
two pugs give me a standing ovation when
i walk
through the door okay trixie you know so
i would think that i would not
you know what about kiki and vandalway
that didn't that didn't ever came across
or coco no that's uh yeah
actually that's that's not a bad idea
oh marvel appreciated that but yeah so
what what what would you say is your
you know as your um in your final what i
hope
six games uh calling nba um
your your your favorite nba moment what
would that be
that you were at a mic for that you'll
remember that you would want people to
you know um that might somebody might
remember
marv for you well there are two moments
because
one was just watching uh when we did the
the dream team in 92 uh in barcelona
and when they played in the tournament
of america's which is the qualifying
round
took place in portland when this group
walked out
on the floor i mean i they're the
greatest group of athletes in the
history of
of team sports i i got the chills when i
saw
them walk out i mean it was even though
they you know just swept through
all the uh basically the entire
tournament they had one close game with
croatia but that was
wasn't even you know you knew what the
final score was going to be
so that was a different kind of moment
you're looking at jordan and bird and
magic and
alone ewing barkley you know the whole
group chris mullin uh
uh he i've never seen a team like that
even any all-star team did compare
to that over the years but in terms of a
moment also
there were there were two of them in
terms of
uh actually playing moments back to
1970 when some of our older generation
fans
may recall when willis reed was not
supposed to play in the 1970
seventh game finals against the lakers
and at the last moment walked onto the
garden court
and then hit two jump shots played maybe
22 minutes
and uh the knicks were inspired to beat
the lakers that was the loudest crowd i
have ever
heard when he walked out from right
under our uh broadcast booth
and the other was michael jordan in the
flu game
in utah with the performance that he put
on
and then as he went back on time out to
the huddle
at the bench with teammates like scottie
pippen and
uh and other bill caught right you know
helping him back to the bench
and he looked like he was he looked like
he was going to faint and he'd sit on
the bench
you know recover go back out and
continue to play
uh jordan style basketball it was
unbelievable to see that kind of emotion
and well i put those two up top
and what about the nfl um marv you
calling games for nbc sports on
television and then
super bowls on westwood one what about
the nfl for you
the most significant there were also
there were
i would say the david tyree catch
against the patriots when he had
held it against his helmet the
miraculous
catch with eli manning throwing the pass
that that was
uh that was probably most significant
uh as one who followed the giants
for you know you lose your uh
you you have to be objective you you
lose your fan
uh i would say uh
you you're no longer a fan when you're
doing these things but
uh that really struck me that was uh
that was incredible
so uh with hockey was the uh
rangers finally winning the stanley cup
in 1994
uh that i thought would never happen
and they did they beat vancouver in game
seven at the garden
well marv this means the world that you
would call me before your
uh final games and uh on a birthday
and i i've embarrassed you this way
before and i don't
uh you know and i i know you're you you
probably expected
you know me to maybe put you in this
position because i i don't care cause
i'll do it
i do i honestly i i do what i do for a
living uh
because of you and growing up in staten
island new york um
and watching you on wnbc and listening
to you call nicks
and rangers games it it it made me want
to do the job
it made me want to do this you were the
voice of
so many great sports moments for me and
i just wanted to do this
and the fact that i have an opportunity
to tell you this in front of
anybody who will listen or see it it
means the world to me
it really does you and and i i know i'm
not the only one who's in this business
because of you and um i just wanted to
say thank you
thank you so much for reading that's so
nice yeah i'm very kind i i really
appreciate that and i
i wish you continued success it's so
it's wonderful to see how
what you have achieved and uh
you know even even in my retirement if
you're looking for a guest
i'm here oh well i will i will take you
up on that marv
and um and this is strange but as the
ultimate thank you
um i will suggest if you haven't seen
shit's creek yet you should you should
see it it's interesting
well i'm a great fan of chris elliott
from uh yes from
the vladimir uh with letterman and chris
uh i i was i thought was terrific from
starting out as the man under the seats
i don't know if you recall of course
in the nbc days right through his
impressions
so i i'm going to i'm going to
eventually get to that over the summer
everybody says the same thing with your
imagination it is terrific and he's
great in it and marv you are the the
greatest
um having an uh an enjoyable time
calling uh the rest of these eastern
conference finals
uh best to heather and may you uh
get everything you want out of
retirement thank you thank you i really
appreciate it thanks
you bet you're the best that's marv
albert oh my god he just called
knew that one will get you i mean come
on
i'll never knew that when we get you i
i'm very fortunate to do what i do for a
living and very fortunate to have done
it for as long as i have
because you know nfl network put out a
very nice birthday wish today
and um you know it's me and my first
um i think my first pr shoot as the
uh host of nfl network looks like i am i
look like a child
well you look like jack wilson no but i
am not i
don't know the problem is i don't look
like zach wilson
i've never looked like zack wilson it's
gradually ever i will never look like
jack wilson
but i do have a baby face at age 33
all right but but i'm never going to sit
here and i'm i'm never going to be jaded
i will never be jaded ever
that is one of the coolest things of all
time as i told reggie jackson today
my god like if uh if you told me at age
seven age eight
marv hey you watched all the way to the
end
thanks for that watch more right here